[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  hey Conan I'm doing great what have you  got for us this week  man I got nothing  you've got nothing no I just got back  from vacation how's that one of those  private Caribbean resorts where there's  no television no internet no newspaper  just Sun and sand well you do look very  relaxed man I ain't never been so mellow  in that peace with the world huh see you  haven't heard anything about Donald  sterling of the clippers or Clyde Bundy  nope  but those are some cool names who are  they  okay I am I my phone here I'm gonna pull  up some news links right here just check  out these stories right there this has  been this weekend Joseph  [Applause]  [Applause]  now which those were real EMTs all right  okay and he still has your phone that's  one of nine things in that schedule a  chance